there are over 80 examples of women who
either lost out on opportunities or
scholarships you have Mary Gregory I
believe in powerlifting you have women
cycling a record that was set you have
examples across the board in
weightlifting in cycling in swimming in
track yeah
um not to mention Combat Sports where
women can actually be physically harmed
so yeah it has happened quite a bit now
granted it's such a small percentage of
the population
what I want to avoid is that
intellectual fallacy of appeal to
novelty well since we haven't done it
yet therefore there are no consequences
well it's just because we haven't done
it yet this is very very new and where
we have implemented these uh types of
policies we've seen an unbelievable
differential between the biological
males and women it's just we've only
been doing this for a few years it's
like saying well there are no negative
consequences to a 90 income tax yet sure
but if we implement it tomorrow and it
takes five years to see all the
bankruptcies right it's not really an
argument so